a week before the pandemic just as the
world was shutting down my next guest
released her memoir untamed its message
that we can do hard things
came at the perfect time for a lot of us
what
to date it sold over 2 million copies
and spent 65 straight weeks on the new
york times bestseller list
so what i i read it i not only read it
i'm like that
nerd that literally i had a necklace
made of a freaking cheetah i'm not
kidding
i i'm so in i'm one of those people that
she's gonna run from at like events like
lectures or something
um but now she has a new project which i
already know about
um it's a podcast called we can do hard
things
and we have her on the line right now so
everybody give it up for glenn and doyle
i literally i was like she's gonna
either think it's cute or be like stage
five klinger
um i did i was like you know what i just
want a symbol i just want to see it
because i was like a tattoo was a lot so
i was like i'm just gonna make so you
know that's i don't know it's permanent
and i have a lot
so i got a necklace made i'm not creepy
i promise
i love it i love it so much so
you you typically bring people together
but you and your wife abby set off a
fierce
online debate regarding dishwashers yes
she is so
controlling about the dishwasher kelly
sometimes
i load it and she will reload it when i
leave the room
so it's more organized i don't know what
people's problem is
about doing that i'm not sure well um
uh just to let you know i have found her
doppelganger and that is me i am abby
i am the one i'm like just stop
like i'll do it um but we have the video
that kicked this off it's awesome
this is a kerfuffle what are you talking
about
[Music]
this is not how you pack the dishwasher
it's gonna wash the sink no no no no
here's the problem
when i redo this it wouldn't even need a
wash we could wait a whole day you know
what you
oh you're going to redo this you are
unbelievably
dish controlling i don't know
glennon
should be tamed is what i'm saying
because i saw that and i was like oh my
god and if there's food on it i can't
like i don't think you need to like
watch it but like there's not tiny
people in the dishwasher like
scrubbing it for you you know so you
gotta do it i am
100 abby on this one so you have lost me
in this
um but i want to say it's nice though
that
to have a partner like in life that will
do the dishes with you i'll say that
um but abby abby is a gold medalist and
world cup champion and now she's
coaching your daughter that's so cool
i know she was coaching just a couple
weekends ago and they were going into
penalty kicks and i walked over to her
and i said are you good
and she looked very cool on the outside
and she said i've never been this
nervous not in the world cup
not in the olympics she was terrified
but she's an amazing coach to the girls
oh that's so
what a cool thing to just have in your
house like to learn wow it's
impressive and speaking of your daughter
i absolutely love this story
she wrote and sing the theme song for
your podcast and
i want to show a little bit of it
because we're adventurers and
heart breaks on map a final destination
we lack we've stopped asking
directions to places
they have never been
you better go ahead with that vibrato
i was this her idea completely her idea
she wrote the lyrics on the way to
soccer practice one day she is going to
absolutely die when she sees that you
are talking
about her song right now she's going to
die oh my god
i was so impressed oh thank you
so how did it all come about is it i
heard that brandi was involved randy
carlyle
yeah so brandi's a dear friend of our
family tish wrote this little song
i sent it to brandy and brandy said
glennon this is a really good song
and then she sent it back to us all
produced up and she sang
background for tish and it's just tish
is such a sensitive little girl
and it's so wonderful to have her find
music
as a way to express herself and show her
heart it's
100 i mean the arts are for empaths like
i think that's where you feel everything
and you express everything i
100 um so this podcast though is a
family affair so can you tell us about
it everyone's kind of involved right
well i mean we started it during covid
so we weren't like allowed to be with
anyone but the family
so those were your options
my options were just sitting at my
kitchen table right we had to work with
what we had
but um i really i started started um
recording it with my sister
and my sister has been my i call her my
lobster she's been my person since
i was three years old and um we've spent
our entire life
talking about hard things and healing
from everything together
and so now i get to she's just like the
best thing i have and now i get to give
her to the world
through this podcast and it's just been
such a joy oh i have a sister like that
as well um
my older sister is well and nobody ever
thinks she's my older sister she'll love
that i said that
um but but she's she's my my lobster as
well
it's so interesting because i think that
sometimes we make the mistake of
thinking okay it's my job and especially
for women okay
it's my job to make sure that everybody
on my island
loves and respects and accepts me and my
family
and i think actually it's like no
our our job and and joy
is to only allow people on our island to
already
do respect and love
and celebrate us
amen those that are deserving um i'm
back with best-selling author and
activist glenn and doyle y'all give it
up for her
that was a clip from her new podcast we
can do hard things
um the pandemic though it upended life
as we know it
and as the world gets back to somewhat
normal glennon has advice for how we can
navigate this transition and i'll take
all the advice and make all the
necklaces about it
um well some of our audience members
have questions for glenn
mullane from seattle uh what's your
question for glennon
so you guys all have multiple kids we
have three boys
ages uh 16 13 and 12.
and each one of them is navigating this
back to normal so differently
our oldest is probably my our most
introverted but he's got the baseball
and the sports and that's helping our
middle child is our free spirit has a
nice group of friends he's smack in the
middle of middle school
so he's doing pretty well our youngest
has withdrawn during all this and
he's artist like he's this sweet
sensitive one that always has had a lot
of friends and has been great with
adults and so
i'm just wondering what suggestions you
have for how to
um navigate this with them individually
and and give them support that they need
okay elaine here's how i feel about
these little ones
i just don't want us to forget that we
have all been through a
huge trauma right none of we're just
like all expecting to go back to normal
and everyone should be normal
but we've all been through so much
and these kids have experienced stuff
that we've never experienced right
and our sensitive ones have been feeling
it all
so they might have the longest process
of
recovering and going back to normal
right
but remember what we talked about over
and over malaine that being human
is not about feeling happy all the time
it's about
feeling everything right so we just
we just be so relentlessly tender and
gentle with these little ones
and we let them to recover um at
whatever pace they are recovering
and we don't rush them and we don't push
them
back into normalcy we just allow them to
feel it all and we let them
see us feel it all right we let them see
us a little anxious and scared and
and when they the more fully human they
see us being the more fully human they
will allow themselves to be
thank you but thinking about that no it
is
it is funny i don't know if this is a
good or bad thing and maybe you can
answer or give you know enlighten me
with what you think um
glennon but i my daughter feels
everything how you describe your
daughter is 100 river
and she feels everything in the room she
takes it all on everyone's emotions she
can't she's a walking little me
but is it good or bad you think to say
because even last night like
we were talking about something and i
was like okay it's okay to be frustrated
and angry
totally okay i just don't i don't think
it's good maybe if we sit in it all
night
like let's talk about it and let's do it
but let's not sit in it
i was like we can have a moment if you
need to do it every day and you need to
talk about this because
we're you know our family is going
through a divorce so it's like we can
talk about it let's go
let's i want to go there but i don't
want to sit in this like emotion all day
is that bad or
not or i don't know kelly i have the
exact same i have this theory that we
just pendulum parents so
i felt like my parents didn't give me
enough space to feel my feelings so then
i accidentally taught my kids that they
should feel
all their feelings all the time and
sometimes i'm watching tish
talking about her feelings for the
second hour and i'm like you know what i
did you wrong
i should have taught you to suffer
silently right like this
we just over do it okay and kelly i said
several times
lots of times to these kids you may
continue feeling your feelings i just
need you to do it in your room
away from me just as a parent
oh my god that was amazing and thank you
malay what a great question a lot of us
uh parents are struggling with that all
our kids are experiencing
i'm not just the pandemic but you know
the previous administration whatever
side of the fence you are it was very
intense and it was constantly
something happening it's been a rough
few years like no matter what side of
the fence you're on
it's been hard for kids and adults so
like you said there's been a lot of
trauma
um and everybody we can do hard things
with glennon doyle is available wherever
you get your podcast do yourself a favor
and listen um and don't forget to pick
up untamed i promise you'll love it
and if you don't then you're wrong yep
i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help